iron man no you nice day away hi hi
welcome thank you - yep
millennial Falcon
this is McGarrett hi guys a geek bomb
that's right that geek bomi's my channel
a lot of it star wars watch this instead
guys so it's usually just trailer
breakdowns and me going more okay they
can watch those yeah did you know that
Disney now they're starting their own
streaming service so the speculation is
people are thinking similar to Netflix
yep they're gonna have like streaming
exclusive content I mean anything can
really happen in this day and age and
I've pitched a lot of like what I would
like to see in the universe because what
Star Wars has done a very good job was
it called at Star Wars not the Luke
Skywalker story mm-hmm because that's
how Harry Potter screwed up yeah it's
not the wizarding world of Hogwarts it
was called Harry Potter and so as soon
as his story finished they tried to do
another one it's like yeah we don't care
pretty bad but Star Wars is not just
about the Skywalker
it's about obviously the galaxy far far
away mm-hmm okay so out of all the Star
Wars Expanded anything's what content
would you like to see appear on a
streaming service I would love a Sith
Academy show I think what happens if
you're in the Sith Academy and you
realize that you're not all evil because
you don't tell anyone because you're
gonna die but I think that's a
fascinating thing because I noticed
originally with Star Wars it was dealing
with good and evil until they've come
out and said it's not good and evil look
at the light and the dark side yeah and
I think that they're showing a little
bit more about the force the the gray
Jedi I'm being in the middle again I
think the new trilogy is gonna be as we
get our got a gray ray Greg correct it's
EADS nothing else right nothing I love
the idea of like an evil Dumbledore that
would be great like the evil Sith person
where it's like they're a cool teacher
and they have nuance but they're also
teaching children to be evil yes that
would be great not evil
evil embracing the dockside okay fine it
would be like Disney's descendants but
Star Wars
you could have baby Darth Maul but she's
like a doll with brushable hair you
could have baby kind of spikes goal the
spikes come out like a little um ears
like two little cat ears so it almost
looks like a little headband accessory
they spoke out through the the nice long
hair
mullet it would just be like Monster
High but Star Wars which is something
that we could get yeah that would sell
better than forces of destiny it's not
the Star Wars characters it's their
children who are inspired by them but
have fashionable outfits and purple hair
it'd be called fit hi North Academy yeah
buts its Academy can beat a live-action
serious one and then sit high can be the
Monster High where it's flash enjoyed
benefits 6:30 news x2 girls
yes it's junior high yeah yeah we're
getting the obi-wan standalone yeah see
that's why I wish they'd have the
streaming service earlier is I feel that
like crappy prequels about characters we
don't care about should be banished to a
streaming service content we never gonna
feed gravis again probably no no what is
I'm not upset about grievous grievous
and some people like advocates for it
there was a team Grievous no people
really do you know his Thomas for what
do they know I stay away what do they
like about him that he was like he was
taught by Duke who I think with like
this like saber techniques why do you
like got forearms I don't personally I
think a ydz
like him so much definitely don't why do
you hate him so much
because he's a wheezing joy yeah he's
the worst with a tiny little feel to
fears
if midi-chlorians are in your blood
where's the heat way at all he's got a
little hot yeah that's just got
10-minute chlorines in it the force had
made so much sense and then they went to
put science behind it yeah would you be
interested in like a legends mini-series
where it's the old stories that aren't
even Canada anymore but you're seeing
like Mara Jade you're seeing the Thrawn
Trilogy
well I used to I used to kind of hold on
to hope because I think the Mara Jade
stories were my favorites out there but
now with the additional throne being
pulled in I think they're going you
legends there's a lot of things that we
can use or not and bringing thrown in it
was done in a way I liked I read the
book I thought that was clever and liked
hearing all about his history and of the
the chiss yeah god I got kissed last
night nope
you don't call it that and you don't I
know what pun you're making though thank
you there is B we have a pun game for
you yeah I heard you're good at puns you
know so my favorite Disney Princess is
Rapunzel Wow but you came with that
pre-prepared see these ones are off the
cuff sign me in prompt number one Star
Wars restaurants okay like Taco Bell or
ghana buffalo x-wings sabar bar Binks
[Music]
was right there like literally from
space bar yeah first to the hut
yeah next pun prompt we have Star Wars
superheroes the DOS awakens
that's good a bit of a stretch great no
it's perfect quiet man go Jin now gonna
top that I hate it light saber tooth
tiger oh that's good that's good yeah I
keep thinking Green Lantern Reed Islands
and Greenland Oh Calrissian a guard
we got one H for that one bar average
but we both the limit so that's that's
important okay next one we have Star
Wars bands the crummy example is 21
x-wing pilots Palpatine a Turner but
your back rack my lease ice noodles qui
Bon Jovi what what's that I'll just max
nobody music fans Star Wars fashion this
might be worse Hugo Boss ness
I don't know the names of designer
clothing no we're doing this lunch you
could do Peter Bossk as well oh that's
better
obi-wan Kenobi Qin Emperor Palpatine
jeans or so
jeans are sold a okay that's good okay
fine next category no we do Star Wars
apps the example is tattoo heath degree
Shazam Wessel the assassin from from
Episode two
captain fast buck the worst game I've
ever played so you know what just
occurred to me yeah so this streaming
service isn't just Star Wars no it's
gonna be all of Disney yeah she's Marvel
they could do like you know least always
like every movie would have like a
spin-off show on the Disney Channel like
Little Mermaid the series allowed in the
series they kept like reboot allowed in
the series you know what did you did you
go to d23 no okay did you hear about
they showed a clip from wreck-it Ralph
where's all the princesses hanging out
at each other that would be a good
streaming series castle they all hang
out together in the princess ki I
actually the record Ralph my favorite
part of that was when they were all
sitting around all the villains so I
kind of loved ya there so a new record
off they have that where it's all the
princesses it was a weird choice but I
think that would be a good like
streaming series to go online they did
like a merchandising thing to where at
one point the princesses are like let's
get into comfy clothes and then they're
all dressed up like the hipster
princesses where they're wearing like
cute pajama Burson's of their outfits
and you're like - pretty so nightshirt -
yeah I've been in her hipster PJs yeah
it's gonna be on makeup bags and stuff
how often do you hear the sound of money
you know I'm watching it c-23 it was
constant just the cash register ding
sound yeah yeah the whole time but do
you think with all these different
series and such they have too much Star
Wars do you think they're over
saturating the market or have they
already guys clothing merchandise
there's comic books there's books
there's the theme park
there's my gosh what else like clothes
panels there's a Star Wars Hospital so
in terms of like is there too much Star
Wars
yes I don't think the threat is going to
be in a streaming service though I think
that's right it's gonna be like you're
saying with the Disney Princesses
getting into a new outfit boom they're
gonna sell all of that well ma
yeah that's my name guess what happens
now you read out something on that card
I read out something on that card it's
my comments from the audience it's
called the general agreement says I get
to hear all the room for me you know
what happens to you during the segment
you leave oh because I talk about me you
go away if you could just like oh look
at me just to find yourself yeah hide
your face
yep just pretend you're not there you
can't be drinking water and just hide
completely okay okay let's see first
comment is from John l-31 one who said
hi Jenny are you excited to board the
Millennium Falcon at Star Wars land
well yes John I can't wait there's so
much to see and do it Star Wars Lin
galaxy's edge opening in Disneyland in
2019 and in Disney's Hollywood Studios
if you're in Florida next question is
from Andre Porter who said you should
get Maude Garrett on here
no Andre never never
this next comment is from worms
animations have you heard of them no
where's animation said finished
animating my new worms comedy episode
and needed a break click to see what was
up on screen junkies and found this in a
word not particularly funny a little
annoying feels overly accident not
natural right back to worms making Lego
that's not in a word that was at least
three dozen anywhere attended but you
know what it does to be fair sound like
whatever he's making is like a lot more
fun than what we just names it ones wo
or WI no wo not like a dragon like a one
it's like a worm with a hat yeah okay
bye we're gonna go watch worms
animations bye bye
goodbye
[Music]